the French president has warmly welcomed
Donald Trump in Paris ahead of
celebrations commemorating the end of
World War one appearing in front of the
press Emmanuel macron tried to show
through body language that the bromance
between the two heads of state is still
alive
[Music]
there were some hiccups leading up to
the meeting just hours before Trump
lashed out on social media over macarons
suggestion that Europe should create its
own army we can now cross live to Daniel
Hawkins in Paris Daniel tell us how are
the two leaders getting on so far
well presidents Trump and macron have
long been fond of their very close
personal friendship as well as
emphasizing the importance of that
transatlantic alliance that was sealed
of course last year zero microns first
official visit to the United States how
simple things seemed back then since
then things have not gone so smoothly as
they were 70 world leaders gather here
in Paris to commemorate the hundredth
anniversary of the end of the First
World War
Trump marked his arrival by taking as
usual to Twitter to say he was insulted
by none other than his great friend
president Mac Ron this is what he wrote
president McCrone of France has just
suggested that Europe build its own
military in order to protect itself from
the US China and Russia very insulting
but perhaps Europe should first pay its
fair share of NATO which the u.s.
subsidizes greatly for those comments of
course referred to an interview macron
gave early this week on the radio in
which he said he favored the creation of
a joint European military task force and
nine country task force to address
various threats civilian evacuations
natural disasters and also defending
from state threats with one particular
country unusually thrown in to that list
we need a Europe which defends itself
better alone without just depending on
the United States in a more sovereign
manner macron is the European
integration asti's long favored the
creation of an independent European
military force
aside from NATO to address these issues
and that really seems to have riled
Trump very much who has previously of
course criticized the lack of NATO
contributions from some European
countries as Trump arrived here in Paris
it was all as we saw earlier smiles
handshakes thumbs up for the camera but
the key differences do remain very much
behind the scenes the Iran nuclear deal
from as one of them has been a key
snipping sticking point with France
Germany the UK expressing regret and
concern in a joint statement that the US
was pulling
of that issue trade tariffs have been
one particular sticking point as well
not to mention of course Trump's pulling
out of the 2015 Paris climate the cause
which was roundly criticized by many
European leaders commemoration is of
course the main reason world leaders
have gathered here in Paris this weekend
but everybody knows there are key
pressing international issues to discuss
and resolve behind the scenes and with
these differences remaining the question
is can they come to some sort of
consensus or will simply more
stumbling-blocks be created over the
next day or so artis Daniel Hawkins in
Paris thank you for bringing us that
report